[Music]
on this Monday night things get testy at
the emergencies act inquiry and you
don't recall saying that you'll cut off
Dave Springer's nuts and use them as
bookends one questions for ottawa's
former police chief and the claims he
tried passing the buck over failures in
policing the Convoy
breaking news shots fired police
investigate a deadly school shooting in
Toronto
Russia's latest barrage on Ukraine
the ramifications for neighboring
countries
indicted the new charges against the BC
man accused of violently attacking Nancy
Pelosi's husband
and modernizing Remembrance Day it's
been a few years in the making fresh
ways to honor service and sacrifice
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us the
former Chief of ottawa's Police Service
was defending his reputation today at
the inquiry into whether the use of the
federal emergencies ACT earlier this
year was warranted in February
protesters were allowed to occupy the
nation's capital for weeks the so-called
Freedom Convoy ended after the
emergencies Act was invoked
ottawa's former police chief Peter
slowly quit in mid-February after
concerns about his lack of leadership
and today evidence was put before the
inquiry that he feared being blamed and
sometimes crudely threatened those who
may have been getting in his way David
Aiken has our top story tonight
do you remember that again I don't even
know what day you're on right now I said
February 9th the clashes were frequent
and tense you were pretty concerned that
you would lose your job and be blamed
for what had happened absolutely not sir
the lawyer for the Ottawa Police Force
spent the morning grilling Peter slowly
the Ottawa Police Chief who resigned
Midway through last Winter's occupation
and what you were looking for was to
blame somebody else absolutely not sir
and yet the evidence shows that slowly
while he was Chief and while the
protesters were on Parliament Hill was
clearly concerned about his own
reputation Navigator a public relations
firm was hired by the police to monitor
media mentions of the chief and provide
Communications advice the bill more than
a hundred and eighty thousand dollars
for two weeks work in a memo slowly
wrote at the time slowly complained
about the personal agendas of some of
his subordinates saying he was dealing
with quote undermining cliques and camps
within his force a letter from the city
of ottawa's lawyer was entered as
evidence in which the lawyer writes he
was worried slowly was scheming to blame
City officials not police for being
unable to clear the Convoy it's an
alarming assertion made by the by the
council for the city and absolutely
incorrect the commission her testimony
from one of slowly's deputies that at
one meeting slowly used salty language
to threaten an opp inspector Named Dave
Springer if Springer got in his way and
you don't recall saying that you'll cut
off Dave Springer's nuts and use them as
bookends and use them as bookends
no sir I don't recall saying that
time and again slowly said he could not
recall or could not remember things that
other Ottawa Police and OPP officers
noted in writing at the time slowly was
particularly harsh in his assessment of
ottawa's Deputy police chief Trish
Ferguson she's the one who made that
note about that crude comment my
evidence commissioner is at her
extreme editorial license that she took
was extremely problematic for me and
reflects on her not on Me Slowly did say
though that in his 30 years of Municipal
policing the freedom Convoy that he
confronted was what he called a true
threat to National Security David we've
heard almost exclusively David from
police so far in these hearings there's
a long list of witnesses still to go
including the Prime Minister what can we
expect for the rest of the week well for
the rest of the week we get to the
protesters themselves the leaders of the
Convoy many of whom are still awaiting
criminal trials related to their Convoy
activities and those leaders those
witnesses will include Tamara Leach
Chris Barber B.J dictor and Pat King as
for the Prime Minister well he and some
of his senior cabinet ministers they're
going to be among the last group of
witnesses all right David Aiken in
Ottawa thanks David two breaking news in
Toronto there's been a shooting outside
a high school police say one person is
dead a second person a teenage boy is in
the hospital the school was placed under
lockdown the suspect was last seen
fleeing the scene Global's Brittany
Rosen is there tonight Brittany what
more can you tell us
good evening Donald well this remains a
very active scene outside of Woburn
Collegiate Institute in Scarborough as
police continue to investigate this
Brazen daylight Halloween shooting that
quickly turned fatal they continue to
have really the whole property cordoned
off and it's believed that the shooting
happened at the front of the school in
the parking lot now what we can tell you
at this point is that two teenage boys
are among the victims one of them had
life-threatening injuries he was rushed
to hospital where he later succumbed to
his injuries the other teenage boy
actually walked into a hospital with a
gunshot wound and he was transferred to
a Trauma Center via emergency run now
Witnesses and students that we spoke to
here on scene say that this may have
stemmed from a confrontation involving
students from other schools so as a
result of all of this students here at
Woburn Collegiate Institute were placed
into lockdown they were in lockdown for
roughly 40 minutes at this point what we
know about the suspect is that he fled
the scene wearing a black jacket and a
coveted mask police say at this point
they haven't made any arrests when it
comes to the suspect however there is no
threat to Public Safety but certainly
Donna this was a frightening day for
students and parents alike and I should
also mention that this is the second
school shooting here at Woburn
Collegiate to happen within this past
year I'll send it back to you Brittany
Rosen at the scene of a school shooting
in Scarborough thanks Brittany the war
of words between Ontario education
workers and the provincial government is
heating up the government of Premier
Doug Ford has announced new anti-strike
legislation ahead of a planned walkout
on Friday the province intends to impose
a new contract and fine education
workers up to four thousand dollars a
day should they strike QP which
represents 55 000 educational assistants
Early Childhood Educators and custodians
is vowing to fight the new legislation
and the union representing Ontario
Elementary School teachers also walked
away from contract talks with the
government today
in British Columbia a new payment model
for doctors is being introduced to try
to tackle the province's ongoing
shortage of family doctors under the
agreement of full-time family doctor
could earn up to 385 thousand dollars a
year up from 250 000 under the old
funding model doctors will be able to
opt out of the current fee for service
system and the payment model is intended
to cover much of the overhead involved
in running a family practice about 1
million people in BC do not have a
family doctor let's hope this will help
retain existing doctors and Recruit new
ones plus better integrate Health Care
Services
this brand new model takes into account
five factors including the time doctors
a doctor spends with a patient the
number of patients a doctor sees in a
day the number of patients a doctor
supports through their office the
complexity of the issues a patient is
facing and administrative costs
currently paid directly by family
doctors
the BC government will also launch a
province-wide database to try to match
people with a general practitioner
to the war in Ukraine now Russia
launched a fresh wave of attacks across
the country today and while Ukraine says
a number of the missiles were
intercepted others did hit their targets
knocking out critical infrastructure and
cutting off power and water to many
including in the capital Kiev as Crystal
gemancing Reports power cuts are the new
normal as winter Looms
with morning temperatures in the single
digits people waited outside to get
water from emergency filling stations in
Kiev
we can stand in line they the Russians
says the 74 year old wouldn't be able to
handle this
attacks on critical infrastructure in
the capital and right across the country
prompted early morning rocket warning
sirens and a flurry of activity for
utility Crews uh experts right now
working and we hope it's we fix a
problem in the next couple of hours it
seems as fast as repairs are made
systems are knocked out Ukraine's prime
minister noted the attacks hit 18 mostly
energy related facilities in harkiv one
such strike left people sitting in the
dark on Metro trains the latest barrage
of missile strikes followed a weekend
Ukrainian drone attack on Russian
vessels in the Black Sea video appearing
to show the strike popped up on social
media Russia reported damage to one
warship the vessels according to Russia
were in the Crimean Port as a part of
the deal to guarantee the safety of
shipments carrying Ukrainian grain
fertilizers and other food products
Russia has pulled out of the that
agreement prompting concerns about food
security Moldova meanwhile has been
dragged into the conflict the Deputy
Prime Minister tweeted that debris from
a missile intercepted by Ukraine caused
damage in a Northern border Village
writing the Shockwave shattered windows
on several residential houses he added
the appalling strike on critical
infrastructure reverberates Beyond
Ukraine's borders and pose a threat
direct to moldova's energy and human
security
Norwegian officials meanwhile say
Russia's invasion of Ukraine poses the
most serious security situation in
Europe in decades as a precaution Norway
put its military on a raised alert level
effective November 1st Crystal gomancing
Global News London the Canadian
government says the first of 39 made in
Canada light armored vehicles have begun
arriving in Europe destined for Ukraine
that's on top of 100 canadian-made
armored personnel carriers already on
the ground there here's the defense
minister in an exclusive interview with
global news
what we are providing to Ukraine are
brand new vehicles fresh off the line to
make sure that Ukraine has Best in Class
technology
there are questions though about whether
this contribution meets Ukraine's needs
and whether Canada is a leader in
manufacturing armored vehicles our
Ottawa bureau chief Mercedes Stevenson
has a reality check
on the front lines in Ukraine the
life-saving value of armored vehicles
made clear
a Russian mind strike on Ukrainian
troops with no injuries or deaths in a
war that has seen heavy Munitions and
mind strikes kill many the protection
offered by armored vehicles is in high
demand Canada has stepped up by pledging
39 armored vehicles manufactured by
General Dynamics land systems Canada and
another eight armored personnel carriers
from ontario-based Rochelle defense
minister Anita Anand says the government
wants to become a leader in nato in
providing vehicles to Ukraine an angle
the Canadian government has also been
pumping behind closed doors with allies
but how realistic is that promise
armored vehicles land vehicles are a key
focus of the defense industrial base in
Canada and think so it's no accident
that that's what one of the things we
ended up sending to Ukraine Perry said
armored vehicles are a logical choice
for Canada but with an important caveat
the government would have to act quickly
and make significant investments in
order to deliver on the promise there's
no timeline no context Mark Popoff who
led armored combat teams in Afghanistan
stand says he's dubious the minister can
make good on her statements Canada
simply does not have the ability to
manufacture Mass amounts of armored
vehicles and become a world leader in
this compared to our own NATO allies
Canada would likely need other countries
to set aside their National interest in
defense contractors and agree to buy
Canadian instead it's not clear if that
will happen and the Canadian government
would need to commit a lot more than a
few dozen vehicles to help Ukraine that
requires sort of policy follow through
and a Constance provision and and thus
far that's not been
that's not they haven't shown a great
tracker record of that there is however
a Twist in all of this while funding for
armored vehicles plays well in boat Rich
ridings where they're manufactured in
Canada it could also delay how quickly
the Canadian Army gets its own equipment
Donna Mercedes thanks a group claiming
it is going to save America coming up
what's behind a movement in Florida
gaining momentum
[Music]
the economy abortion rights and
immigration are dominating debates in
the lead up to the midterm elections in
the U.S and so is something else lies
the mistaken belief that the 2020
election was stolen and that Joe Biden
is not the legitimate president has
taken hold among millions of Americans
fueled by former president Donald Trump
and his supporters Jackson prosco
traveled to the heart of trump Country
Florida and tonight he looks at a
political movement that claims to be on
a mission to save America
[Music]
Welcome to The Villages an affluent
retirement community where golf carts
rule the road and where many residents
are still working to re-elect Donald
Trump why Donald Trump because I think
he's the best president we've ever had
in my lifetime and I'm 70 years old
and I want him back Valerie Jamison
leads The Village's Mega Club I felt
really safe and secure in this country
and I don't feel that way at all anymore
like most Republicans she's adamant the
last election was stolen because there's
no way Biden would have won without it
being stolen why do you say that because
he's you see how he is she's also
convinced there's no way Democrats can
legitimately win future elections
including the midterms they are the
enemy it's easier fellow Americans
I don't care who they are they can be
American they can be from another
country but if they have kind of views
that the left has
I don't trust them do you have friends
who are Democrats my mother my sister
and what's that like I don't speak
politics to them at all ever Valerie is
hardly alone especially here
at a rally for Republican senator Marco
Rubio the top issue was taking back
power in language that's increasingly
dire
our government is Marxist from the core
do you honestly believe that I do I know
it believe it it's the truth do you
think these elections will be fair and
legitimate not all no if the rhetoric
sounds dangerous that's because it is
Democrats and Republicans fear violence
based largely around Trump's election
lies if those people remain in power
they will destroy the country Senator
Rubio recently claimed without evidence
that one of his campaign staff was the
victim of a politically motivated attack
that was just days before the husband of
speaker Nancy Pelosi was brutally
assaulted at home what can you as a
political leader do to dial down the
temperature well it's illegal I mean I
don't I've never asked anyone to go out
and attack anybody and the line in which
you say and everyone who votes for the
other side is evil and dangerous and
there all need to be destroyed and and
they're a danger to the country that
invites violence back on the road some
of us have thought of actually leaving
the country Trump supporters like
Valerie make no apologies for their
views most people are on the same page
we are Valerie believes the stakes are
so high that only one man can save her
country even if he isn't on the ballot
right now so what do you think the
Republican Party looks like if Donald
Trump decides not to run in 2024 I think
we're doomed whether or not Trump makes
a comeback he has come to define a
movement that sees only one path forward
for America
Jackson prosco Global News The Villages
Florida
the man accused of attacking Nancy
Pelosi's husband in his home has been
charged with assault and attempted
kidnapping 42-year-old David depop was
arrested on Friday and faces 50 years in
prison if convicted State charges have
attempted homicide and elder abuse among
others are still pending Paul Pelosi was
attacked inside with a hammer he
suffered a fractured skull and is
recovering from surgery police say to
Pap claimed he wanted to kneecap Nancy
Pelosi wasn't home at the time and take
her hostage and that duct tape and zip
ties were found in the house the attack
raises questions of security and safety
in the lead-up to the midterm elections
intelligence agencies warn a rise in
domestic terrorism could lead to a spike
in violence
we'll have full coverage next week from
Washington D.C As Americans head to the
polls I will be live from the capitol
looking at some of the factors
influencing this election
trapped in the happiest place on Earth
ahead what China's strict covet policies
mean for Shanghai Disney
people in South Korea are angry grieving
and demanding answers after Saturday's
deadly crowd surge during Halloween
celebrations in Seoul 154 people were
killed in the crush more than 100 of the
victims were in their 20s 26 foreign
Nationals died 149 others including a
Canadian were injured the huge crowd
pushed through a narrow neon-lit
Alleyway trapping and crushing people
investigators are combing through
security camera footage to find the
exact cause of the Stampede a national
period of mourning has been declared
families and friends who lost loved ones
want to know why police sent only 137
officers to try to control a crowd of
more than one hundred thousand people
visitors to Disneyland in Shanghai China
were locked inside the park Gates as
part of that country's latest round of
strict covid-19 lockdowns videos posted
to social media show lots of people
trying to get out before the gates were
fully closed once they were shut people
were told they would not be able to
leave the park unless they tested
negative for covet 19. the restrictions
were imposed as part of China's zero
coveted policy after 10 cases of the
virus were confirmed in Shanghai on
Saturday
innovating tributes next how this year's
poppies are bringing more meaningful
ways to honor those who serve
Remembrance Day is approaching and among
the ways to honor the fall and is of
course to donate to the legion get a
poppy and wear it in the lead-up to
Remembrance Day we've all been doing it
for years this year there's something
slightly different as Mike Armstrong
explains a new batch of poppies carry
deeper tributes plus a touch of
sustainability
hello oh
the Tomb of the Unknown Soldier downtown
Otto on the morning of November 11th
will look very different
it will be decorated with the small
flower that's been a symbol of
remembrance for Canadians for 101 years
a way of honoring those who served and
sacrificed
[Music]
Remembrance Day ceremony at the national
war memorial celebrants lay their
poppies on the tomb it's one of the most
emotional moments of the day
touching symbolism isn't changing but
there may be a slightly different
feeling to the touch it's been a few
years in the making judgment bond is a
spokesperson for the Royal Canadian
Legion and says For the First Time new
poppies are biodegradable the legion
distributes 18 to 20 million poppies
each year that's a lot of plastic well
not anymore they're now being made of
paper and cotton velvet the wreaths are
being changed as well the wreaths are
also biodegradable this year so they're
also a mix of different things like real
moss and bamboo and some plaster
something else that's new this year is
online the legion has a website for cell
phones
popstories.ca you simply scan a poppy
and it gives you the history of someone
who served in this case Canadian
Grenadier guard Sergeant Mo Horowitz he
was a hockey player from Montreal
decorated for heroism in the second
world war and killed at just 25. the
legion has dozens of life stories up and
will add more in the years to come we
really hope that people will make that
personal connection to a name to a face
think about their life think about how
similar they are to you and I now this
is an important part of the year for the
legion the poppy campaign generates
about 20 million dollars money that's
used to support veterans and their
families
Mike Armstrong Global News
Ottawa
get a poppy and that is global national
for this Monday I'm Donna Friesen
tonight's here at Canada is this pumpkin
patch in sanitchton BC looking a little
spooky happy Halloween to all of you out
and about tonight and thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
foreign
[Music]